lucky pups got their freedom flights to
las vegas today retriever rescue of las
vegas rescues dogs from the south korean
meat trade brings them here to the
valley to find their forever homes since
the start of the pandemic flight changes
made it harder for them to get here but
since korean air reinstated its direct
flights from seoul to harry reid it will
give plenty more pups the opportunity
for a new life here in america my dog is
actually from korea from retriever
rescue my good friend who runs the
rescue both of my friends danny and john
they're amazing so they've saved
hundreds and hundreds of dogs and it's
just really phenomenal well the rescue
societies are great i'm fostering a
couple of britney spaniels right now
from the rescue society and i just got
to say please don't leave dogs in cars
and no no no no
try to do it very early in the morning
or well after sunset because their feet
i mean it's they're wearing a fur coat
yeah yeah exactly so what you all are
getting at is that i need one of them
exactly that's really the entire purpose
of this happening right now he landed he
drove here from his last market and i
was like hi logan i'm sasha can you
adopt a dog
and i said absolutely with no questions
i am
exactly exactly but yeah important keep
take care of those animals in the heat
for sure absolutely hydrate them you
know if you have a swimming pool that's
great they jump in but if you don't get
a hose and hold them down there you go
they go fashion way yeah then they go in
here and then they jump on your bed and
your shoots are soaking away
the other night
all right we'll be right back